- Bonjour! Bonjour!
- L'heure du magasinage
des Fêtes a sonné.
Dans ce magasin Best Buy
de la rue Sainte-Catherine,
les clients se comptent par
centaine durant l'heure du midi.
- C'est que je travaille
juste à côté. Alors,
c'est pratique pour moi.
- Je suis sa mère.
Ça fait que je surveille
ce qu'elle va acheter.
- C'est vrai?
- Oui, pour ne pas
qu'elle fasse des folies.
- Malgré la crainte d'une
récession qui se profile
à l'horizon, les clients
n'hésitent pas à ouvrir
leur portefeuille.
- J'ai acheté des AirPods.
On achète des cadeae e e Noël
pour la famille.
- Des écouteurs, pour écouter
la télévision sans déranger
mon mari.
- Je dirais téléviseurs,
écoute l l les jeux vidéo.
C'est vraiment les tendances.
- Rémi Sammoun est directeur
chez Best Buy. Il planifie
cette journée depuis plusieurs
semaines, pour laquelle plus
d'une centaine d'employés
sont mis à contribution.
- L'inventaire, aussi,
commence à rentrer
depuis à peu près un mois.
- Si les détaillants ont connu
l'an dernier des problèmes
d'inventaire, il assure que
la situation s'est largement
réglée, cette année. Ce client
n'aura toutefois pas réussi
à mettre la fin sur la
PlayStation 5 qu'il convoitait.
- Il n'y a ni la console,
mais il y a les jeux.
Donc, je vais les acheter
parce que par exemple, FIFA,
il est à -C'C'C'C'est quand même
une sacrée aubaine.
- Combien les Canadiens
prévoient-ils dépenser,
cette année, pour la période
des fêtes? Selon le Conseilnana,
en moyenne, 790 $ au Canada,
590 $ au Québec. Bref,
tout autant que l'an dernier.
- 60 % des gens ont dit qu'ils
seraient davantage, cette année,
à l'affût des rabais.
Donc, c'est beaucoup, beaucoup
plus de gens que par le passé.
- Le président du Conseil
canadien rem mê mê mê mê même cp
que le Vendredis fou a détrôné
le Boxing Day du 26 décembre.
- Aujourd'hui, c'est la journée
où les gens vont acheter,
justement, le pluseeeee
de souliers, le plus possible
de vêtements. Ça fait que...
C'est plus qu'une paire, là,
s'ils viennent aujourd'hui.
- Et la facture grimpe
rapidement, observe
l'assistante-gérante
de cette boutique Foot Locker.
- Entre minimum, je dirais
100 et, des fois, ça peut
aller dans les 1000.
- Alors que de nombreuxCaCaCaCae
en cette période d'incertitude,
d'autres dépensent sans compter.
Ici Hadi Hassin,
Radio-Canada, Montréa